[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend ihnen allen norbert heute
unter anderem über zwei top
entscheidungen im fußball auch ganz
aktuell aus england schon genannt unsere
themen an diesem sonntag
zwölf wochen krieg in der ukraine
geheimdienste befürchten dass neue
schwere russische angriffe bevorstehen
auf der suche nach neuen energie
partnerschaften im senegal beginnt
bundeskanzler scholz seine erste
afrikareise
und eine stadt im freudenrausch leipzig
feiert den ersten pokalsieg seiner
bundesligamannschaft
russland verstärkt die angriffe im osten
der ukraine unter anderem mit einer
großoffensive in lugansk einer der
beiden den bass regionen dort versucht
das russische militär seit tagen
transportwege zu kappen was ukraine
präsident selensky aktuell eine äußerst
schwierige situation nennt fasst axel
conrad zusammen
mahmut im donbass front nas hinterland
heißt es im militärjargon für die
bewohner heißt es raketenanschlag
jederzeit denkbar gestern erst wurde die
universität getroffen ich war gerade auf
dem weg zur busstation das hat mir das
leben gerettet
die angriffe der russen kommen jetzt vor
allem aus der luft hochglanz
propagandavideos des
verteidigungsministeriums zeigen k 52
helikopter im einsatz ein ziel die
städteserien donetsk und musik sollen
keinen militärischen nachschub mehr von
westen her bekommen man will sie ein
kesseln und schließlich den gesamten
donnerstag konnte bringen
hier dagegen hoffen sie das schlimmste
ist jetzt vorbei moskau kiew die russen
sind weg und sneijder kostenko ist
wieder da doch fast alleine in ihrem
dorf hat die 67 jährige schon ehrgeizige
pläne wir werden unseren laden aufmachen
sobald es wieder licht gibt die jungs
arbeiten an den leitungen und denken
ende des monats ist es soweit
wir werden alles wieder aufbauen und
leben wie zuvor
in kiew im parlament begeisterter
applaus für einen ganz engen verbündeten
polens präsident duda betont kiews recht
auf selbstbestimmung
es wird keine verhandlungen und keine
entscheidungen hinter eurem rücken geben
nichts ohne euch das ist ein eisernes
prinzip
von der hauptstadt geht der blick
sorgenvoll auch nach odessa die
momentane ruhe könnte trügen die
russische schwarzmeerflotte das will der
gewinne erfahren haben trifft
vorbereitungen für einen angriff und
dort in odessa für uns ist johannes hano
es gibt auch neue informationen des
ukrainischen geheimdienstes wovor wird
gewann ist
also der ukrainische geheimdienst hat
hier die bevölkerung heute davor gewarnt
dass russische truppen an der grenze zur
ukraine
dabei sind ballistische
kurzstreckenraketen vom typ iskander
scharf zu machen und das lässt auf
nichts gutes hin deuten denn diese
raketen sind für die russen wahnsinnig
wertvoll erstens sind es
präzisionswaffen aber zweitens hat man
nicht mehr allzu viele davon und das
bedeutet dass man sich von dem einsatz
jetzt jede menge verspricht also man hat
angst die in der ukraine dass die russen
im großen stil ein raketenangriff auf
die ukraine anordnen werden der hat vor
allen dingen die strategische
infrastruktur treffen soll und die
truppen im don was die sich da ja immer
noch den russischen truppen massiv
entgegen stellen also da hat man einen
riesen angst davor die bevölkerung ist
gewarnt und so wie es aussieht ist steht
der ukraine schwere stunden bevor live
aus oder ist aber dass johannes hano
vielen dank russland blockiert nach wie
vor getreideexporte aus der ukraine das
verschärft auch die ernährungskrise in
ostafrika sicher ein großes thema aber
der ersten afrika reise des
bundeskanzlers er besucht den senegal
nieder und südafrika thematisch geht es
auch um probleme wie klimawandel
energieversorgung sowie den großen
einfluss von china und russland auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent aus dem senegal
klaus brodbeck
erste afrikareise erste station der carl
seelig als schlüsselpartner deutschlands
und europas führt derzeit den vorsitz
der afrikanischen union ist eines der
beiden afrikanischen länder die der
kanzler zum g 7 gipfel im juni
eingeladen hat olaf scholz ungeübt das
land
unsere aufgabe ist es dabei mitzuhelfen
dass es eine welt ist in der
internationale regeln gelten und in der
wir miteinander solidarisch handeln bei
diesem bestreben kommt es auf jedes
einzelne land an deutschland zählt dabei
auf den weniger es geht um den kampf
gegen terrorismus und die auswirkungen
des ukraine kriegs afrika droht eine
hungersnot senegal hoffte auf deutsches
geld und deutsche technik bei der
erschließung eines gasfelds vor der
küste es wird gepokert ich denke wir
werden mit deutschland einen guten
gesprächspartner finden aber es gibt
auch andere
die breite themenpalette
energiesicherheit die folgen des ukraine
krieges auch aus afrika mit dem
bundeskanzler auf den weiteren stationen
seiner reise erhalten bleiben scholz mit
klar machen dass er den kontinent und
seine sorgen ernst nimmt und damit auch
den wachsenden einfluss russlands und
chinas in der region zurückdrängen auch
deswegen schenk deutschland weniger an
ein solarkraftwerk erneuerbare energie
in afrika
nach zwei jahren corona pause ist es
wieder soweit in davos tag das
weltwirtschaftsforum
bei dem treffen in den schweizer alpen
geht es vor allem um die folgen der
pandemie den ukraine krieg und den
klimawandel fünf tage austausch zwischen
politik wirtschaft und zivilgesellschaft
und anne gellinek ist für uns in davos
geschichte an einem wendepunkt lautet
das motto dort wie sehr ist das zu
spüren und was kann vom treffen ausgehen
dass dieses davoser treffen anders ist
als sonst ist sehr deutlich zu spüren
denn die weltlage hat einen direkten
einfluss auf die gästeliste hier in
davos die russen russland ist komplett
ausgeladen wegen des überfalls auf die
ukraine die chinesische delegation ist
sehr viel kleiner als in den letzten
jahren einerseits wegen der pandemie
andererseits aber auch wegen der
politischen abkoppelung chinas vom
westen der westen redet also im
wesentlichen hier mit sich selbst dazu
kommt die zunehmende spaltung der welt
in blöcke die usa china europa das wirft
die frage auf ob die globalisierung die
internationale arbeitsteilung der
produktion in zukunft noch funktionieren
kann oder ob sie an ihre grenzen gerät
also in der wurst dieses jahr weniger
glitzer mehr nachdenklichkeit dankeschön
anne gellinek nach davos und diese
nachricht kam vor einer guten halben
stunde in nordrhein westfalen wollen cdu
und grüne kommende woche
sondierungsgespräche über eine mögliche
koalition aufnehmen vertreter von cdu
und grünen berichteten dass sich beide
parteien dafür ausgesprochen haben und
zum zweiten mal in dieser woche fussball
bedingte ausnahmezustand dieses mal in
leipzig der neue dfb pokalsieger ließ
sich nämlich von tausenden fans im ganz
großen stil feiern der truck der
siegermannschaft der vor zur großen
sause vor die arena wo wahrscheinlich
noch bis spät in die nacht
weitergefeiert wird
und von den vorbildern jetzt zum
sportlichen erfolg der leipziger norbert
könig das ist ein historischer moment in
der noch jungen vereinsgeschichte dieses
klubs knapp 13 jahre nach dem start des
projektes rb leipzig haben die sachsen
gegen den sc freiburg den ersten großen
erfolg perfekt gemacht in unterzahl eine
stunde überstanden und vom
strafstoßpunkt dann mit den besseren
nerven
den entscheidenden elfmeter verschoss r
medien die niere wird aus vorbei für die
breisgauer obwohl sie die erste halbzeit
dominiert hatten und verdient in führung
gegangen waren maximieren eckstein hatte
schon in der 19 minute getroffen bei
einem konter der freiburger in der
zweiten hälfte riss marcel halstenberg
als letzter mann lukas müller von den
beinen unstrittig roth die leipziger
bäumten sich in unterzahl auf
schließlich der ausgleich durch
christopher punkten nach 76 minuten
schon wieder sieg gefeiert aber erst
nach verlängerung und elfmeterschießen
glückt der pokalerfolg in
einem höchst spannenden fernduell mit
dem fc liverpool hat sich manchester
city auf der zielgeraden den titel in
der englischen premier league gesichert
liverpool hilft der 3 2 1 heimsieg gegen
wolfram dann nicht mehr weil manchester
city auch dann zwei treffern von inka
junioren aus einem 0 2 rückstand gegen
aston villa noch einen 3 2 sieg macht
und damit einen punkt vorsprung auf
liverpool ins ziel rettete city der
achte meistertitel liverpool spielt am
samstag noch das champions league finale
gegen real madrid
die eishockey nationalmannschaft der
männer hat bei der wm in finnland den
fünften erfolg nacheinander gefeiert
nach dem 5 4 gegen kasachstan winkt im
letzten vorrundenspiel gegen die schweiz
sogar der gruppensieg
und max verstappen gewinnt im red bull
den großen preis von spanien es ist der
dritte sieg nacheinander für den formel
1 weltmeister trotz seines ausflugs ins
kiesbett schafft es der niederländer in
barcelona sich wieder nach vorne zu
kämpfen und profitiert anschließend vom
ausfall des führenden scherle klären
ferrari sebastian vettel wird elfter und
bleibt ohne punkte wie auch nixon macher
als vierzehnter verstappen übernimmt die
wm führung mit sechs punkten vorsprung
auf erklärt schluss mit so harten sport
vielen dank norbert wir blicken noch fix
auf die wetteraussichten gehen so im
westen und süden kommen morgen schauer
und gewitter auf am nachmittag und abend
lokal auch mit unwetter starkregen hagel
und schweren sturmböen im norden und
osten ist es länger sonnig temperaturen
20 bis 28 grad
das war es von uns in aller kürze wir
empfehlen noch das heute journal mit
christian sievers um 21 uhr 45 falls sie
morgen um 7 zeit hätten würde uns sehr
freuen